you must have loved eddie van halen
because eddie was always screwing with
his guitar i mean he put together the
frankenstein by just different body
parts that guy was really
out there i mean what a genius yeah he
was a genius
you ever meet him i did and um
it wasn't even that long ago you know we
went down because all my records on
vinyl
were getting a ride down to the the show
you know so we have a drink in the back
and
and i'm looking for some cds or some
and i got nothing so then i remember i
have like a an eight-track it's like a
ghetto blaster but it's for eight tracks
right these kind of red things
and i brought van halen and van halen to
or one and two
on a track and then that's what we
cranked on the way to the tacoma dome
cranking our eight track and then when
we walked in
i said you know what i'm gonna take that
in because and we might
get to meet him and i might even have
him sign this damn thing
and sure enough we did i was a little
nervous because if you're eddie van
halen you can you could
you could be a complete [ __ ] and i
would
uh oh i would totally respect that you
can be however you want if you're eddie
van halen
right it turned out he was the sweetest
sweetest
guy and and i kind of sheepishly said
hey
would it be funny if i asked you to sign
this thing and
he said oh my god look at that he said
wolfie
come here you had his uncle he goes look
at this wolfy looked at it like
you know it's from mars like like the
yeah the the coke bottle and gods must
be crazy or something like he just
didn't know
what is that yeah and he said this is
what we used to put out and explained
how to yeah so i have this nice
um this nice thing where he wrote uh two
eddie from eddie and all that